transformation c maps negative 2 3 to 4
negative 1. so let me do negative 2
comma 3
and it maps that to 4 negative 1
to 4
negative 1.
and
point negative five comma five
negative five comma five
it maps that to seven negative three
two
seven negative three so seven
negative three
and so let's think about this a little
bit how could we get from this point to
this point and that point to that point
now it's tempting to view this that
maybe a translation is possible because
if you imagine the line
if you imagined a line like that you
could say hey let's just shift this
whole thing down and then to the right
these two things happen to have the same
slope they have they both have a slope
of negative two thirds and so this point
would map to this point and that point
would map to that point but that's not
what we want we don't want negative two
three to map to seven negative 3 we want
negative 2 3 to map to 4 negative 1. so
you could get this line over this line
but we won't map the points that we want
to map so this would this
can't be at least i can't think of a way
that this could actually be that this
could actually be a translation
now let's think about
let's think about whether our
transformation could be a reflection
well
if we imagine a line that has see these
both have a slope of negative three
these both have a slope of negative two
thirds so if you imagine a slope that
had a line that had a slope of positive
three halves
a positive three halves that was
equidistant from both and i don't know
if this is let's see is this equidistant
is this equidistant from both of them
it's either going to be that line
or this line
right over or that line actually that
line looks better
so that one and once again i'm just
eyeballing it
so a line that has slope of positive
three halves
so this one looks
right in between the two or actually it
could be some place in between but
either way we just have to think about
it qualitatively if you had a line that
looked something like that and if you
were to reflect over this line
if you were to reflect over this line
then this point would map to this point
which is what we want
and
this purple point negative 5 comma 5
would map to that point it would be
reflected over so it's pretty clear that
this could be a reflection now rotation
actually makes even more sense or at
least in my brain makes a little more
sense if you were to rotate around this
point right over here this point would
map to that point and that point would
map to that point so a rotation also
seems like a possibility for
transformation c
now let's think about transformation d
let's think about transformation d
we are going from 4 negative 1
4 negative 1 so that's 4 negative 1
to 7 negative 3
to 7 negative three actually maybe i'll
put that in magenta as well to seven
negative three just like that and we
wanna go from
negative five five so negative five five
negative five 5
to negative 2
to negative 2 3 negative 2
3.
so i could definitely imagine a
translation right over here
this point went 3 to the right and 2
down this point went 3 to the right
and 2 down so a translation definitely
makes sense
now let's think about a reflection
so it would be tempting
it would be tempting to let's see if i
were to to get from this point to this
point i could reflect around that
but that won't help this one over here
and for to get from that point to that
point i could reflect around that but
once again that's not going to help that
point over there so reflection really
doesn't seem to do the trick
and what about a rotation
well to go from this point to this point
we could rotate around this point
we could go there but that won't help
that won't help this point right over
here while this is rotating there this
point is going to rotate around like
that and it's going to end up someplace
out here so that's not going to help so
it looks like this is this one can only
be a translation